-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm Steve Higgins, and we are
about to play "Pup Quiz"!
-"Pup Quiz"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Playing tonight, we have
the host of the "Tonight Show,"
Mr. Jimmy Fallon.
-Oh, hi, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-And his opponent,
the author of the new cookbook
"Cravings: All together,"
Chrissy Teigen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh!
What a crazy game.
Now, you know, for Halloween,
all our puppies are
dressed up in costumes.
-Oh, my gosh!
-This one is dress as a dead --
oh, skeleton.
It's a skeleton.
It's Gary Frick Jr.
You know him. You love him.
Here's how the game works.
-Aww, he's cute.
-We'll be asking both of you
trivia questions.
Aww! If you answer
the question correctly,
you win
a golden-retriever puppy.
-Oh!
-If you answer it incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
Now, most puppies
at the end of the game wins.
-Okay.
-Chrissy, you are up first.
You ready?
-These stakes are so high.
-I know.
I want to win this so bad.
I got to get the little
skeleton puppy.
-What is the technical name for
a group of bats?
Is it, "A," a haunt,
"B," a cauldron,
or, "C," a party?
-What?!
-Yeah.
-Can I get help?
-If you want to give her
the puppy, sure.
-No, I don't. I want the puppy.
It's definitely "C."
-A party of bats.
-[ Laughs ]
-I think it's a haunt.
-You think it's a haunt?
Is that your final answer?
-Yes.
-Ooh, no!
[ Buzzer ]
It's a cauldron!
-Oh!
-Wait. I thought it
was a haunt, as well, but --
-You get Gary Frick Jr.
-Hi, friend!
-There you go.
-Hi!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Hi, buddy.
-I'm so jealous.
-He smells like --
-He smells like strawberries.
-He smells like a puppy!
-They're in costumes, too!
-Oh, no, he's so cute.
Hi, buddy.
-Alright, Jimmy,
next question is for you.
-Yeah. Love it.
-In your favorite movie,
the 1985 movie "Teen Wolf,"
Michael J. Fox's
basketball team have what
animal as their mascot?
-Wolf?
-No.
-Dragon?
-Maybe.
-Or Beaver?
-It can't be a wolf.
He is a wolf.
-Right. Teen Wolf.
-Dragon doesn't really --
I don't associate dragon with
a high-school team name.
Like, the basketball team,
"We're the dragons."
-Right.
-So I think the Beavers.
I think "C."
-Final answer?
-I think it's Beaver, too.
-I think it's Beaver.
[ Ding ]
-Beaver -- that is correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh!
Jimmy getting the role of
a puppuccino.
This is a Frappuccino
made of puppy skull.
-What is this?
-Mary Kennedy as a puppuccino.
Not a Frappuccino.
A puppuccino.
-Aww!
-It gets better when
there's more of them.
-It's so cute.
They are so cute.
[ Dog barking ]
-You know what that sound means.
-No.
-Time for "Double Puppardy."
-What does that mean?
-Questions are now worth
two puppies!
-Okay, don't scare the puppies.
-Okay.
Ghost sharks.
We all love ghost sharks, sure.
-I don't even know
what that means.
-They have a retractable
sex organ called a "clasper" --
ouch -- that comes out of what
part of their body?
The tail, the forehead,
or the dorsal fin?
The clasper.
-Mm, it's "Double Puppardy."
-Yep, "Double Puppardy."
-Forehead?
-Is that your final answer?
-Yes!
-Forehead! You are right!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh!
-Oh, no!
-A brontosaurus and a chef.
-Oh, no. Oh, no.
-Please welcome Lisa Armstrong
and Peter Winston.
Peter loves cooking,
just like you.
-Oh, no!
Oh, no!
-Oh, there you go.
Oh, look at that
little brontosaur.
-I'm gonna cry.
-Okay, Jimmy.
Okay, Jimmy, how many different
species of spiders are there?
-Oh, easy. I don't even need
the multiple choice.
-Oh, really? Then what is it?
-Just show it for fun.
-Okay, just for the people.
-Just for the audience.
-450, 4,500, or 45,000 spiders?
[ Laughter ]
-We're so happy right now.
-It's the best game.
I don't want it to end.
Well, I think there's
a lot of spiders, right?
-You think there's a lot
of spiders?
-I'm going to say "C,"
45,000 spiders.
-That is correct!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now, your puppies are dressed as
Frankenpup and a rodeo horse.
Say hello to Kyle McAdams
and Michelle Gordon,
the rodeo horse.
-Hi, bud. Ooh! Yeah, sure.
Oh. [ Laughs ]
[ Dog barking ]
-Oh, you know
what that sound means.
Time for "Final Puppardy."
Yep.
-Oh.
-For all of
your opponent's puppies.
[ Both gasp ]
So, pick up the iPads.
This is a numerical one.
-Alright, gotcha.
So this is a numeric --
-Numeric answer.
Whoever's the closest,
up or down,
gets all the puppies.
-Yep, gotcha. Okay.
-Ready?
-Yep, hold on. Rodeo pup...
-How many pounds --
-I think I'm missing a puppy.
Sorry.
I lost one of the puppies.
-Oh, no.
-Oh, where's the skeleton puppy?
Oh, here he is.
-There he is. There's skeleton.
That's Gary Frick Jr.
-No, of course it is.
-How many pounds does
the world's largest
salamander weigh?
World's largest salamander.
You have 10 seconds, starting...
-What do you mean 10 seconds?
-...now!
-Oh, my God!
-9, 8, 7...
-You're scaring the pups.
-Wait. Without going over?
-You can go over.
It doesn't matter.
-Okay.
-World's largest salamander.
[ Buzzer ]
Okay.
Jimmy, what was your answer?
You wrote the word "So."
-No, it should be 50.
-Oh, 50. 50. Of course. 50.
50 or so.
-50 pounds.
-50-or-so-pound salamander?
-20. 20 pounds.
-20 pounds.
The winner is Jimmy!
[ Dinging ]
-No!
-130 pounds!
Oh, my gosh!
-Chrissy, I'm gonna let you
win this one,
just 'cause it's Halloween.
Why not?
Come on. This is so good.
Get these puppies.
-There you go.
-Thank you. Hi!
This is this the best game!
All the puppies!
-There you go.
[ Laughs ]
-I love it!
-Look at these.
Look at all the puppies.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Our thanks to Chrissy Teigen
and all these adorable puppies.
Stick around for more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Happy Halloween!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, guys!
♪♪